notre enquête du jour ça concerne
vincent lagaf a vu quelques déclarations
dans la presse qui ont été faites par la
part vincent il demandé certaines choses
la pub assez incertain vraiment les
femmes enceintes certaines heures donc
la question reste posée
y at il des exigences du côté de vincent
lagaf
c'est donc du cool en quête de caste à
regarder lui c'est vincent roux il plus
connu sous le nom de la gaffe ou encore
de mega caf
en effet l'ancien trublion de tf1 a
passé l'été auprès du père fouras
l'amour de jeunesse d'isabelle
morini-bosc on voit déjà cinq mois que
vincent lagaf fait partie de la grande
famille de ses huit lagaf a même été
accueilli en grande pompe par le
directeur de la chaîne franck appietto
lagaf a présenté un jeu qui va mélanger
culture et bowling
on va l'appeler qui veut gagner des
millions finalement cela s'appellera
strict
côté audience c'est un carton le premier
numéro réuni environ 1,4 million de
téléspectateurs
c'est comme si toutes les ex de benjamin
castaldi étaient devant leurs écrans le
26 septembre prochain strict revient sur
ces 8
sauf que cette fois ci ce n'est plus la
même limonade
vincent a désormais plusieurs exigences
comme par exemple que les horaires des
publicités soient définies à l'avance et
restent fixes que l'émission soit
toujours diffusée le mercredi soir
et pour finir que le programme débute à
21h12 alors que tout le monde sait que
cyril hanouna ne rend pas l'antenne
avant 23h alors vincent lagaf at-il
raison d'avoir des exigences va-t-il
bientôt exiger que la production lui
fournisse un coiffeur à plein temps et
surtout est ce que jean michel maire
n'aurait pas caché une grille de strict
dans son slip longtemps de questions
auxquelles le capitaine casta va tenter
de répondre
[Musique]
ok pas sauter savait donc répondu non ça
beau s'afficher ou pas alors à gilbert
ds vous êtes choqué et extrêmement
choquant mais qui est la gaffe
franchement non mais attendez attendez
jusqu'à preuve du contraire il n'est pas
producteur de son émission donc il n'a
pas décidé à quelle heure cyril hanouna
arrête pour que monsieur est la place
lille avait été en émission à lui
laisser jouer
il ne peut pas décider des coupures peut
on dire une star hollywoodienne et ses
caprices
je les aime beaucoup la gaffe mais là il
a complètement perdu la tête et je passe
au québec parce qu'il a ce qu'est là que
je trouve que ce sont des exigences qui
vont servir le programme elle servira à
monter en grade le programme ça super
pour elle c'est la création régionale
s'est produit en plus de pub par la
maison donc je pense que c'est bon
élément surnaturel et qu'on peut
suggérer à une chaise c'est ça c'est pas
à lui de décider qu est-ce qui va faire
grimper le droit ou pas nous laisser
gérer un directeur de programme qui est
là pour ça lui les animateurs il fait ce
qu'on lui demande il ya quinze jours
était encore en jet-ski maintenant il
fait des missions de créer maintenant il
va il me l'ont comme ça vous savez c'est
une sphère lopez 5 ans la gaffe a tenu
pendant des années l'accès à des pannes
en 2010
oui il avait il m'arrive aussi non quand
tu dis maintenant mais il a toujours été
comme ça la gaffe on le prend ou on le
laisse
il a toujours été un géant un chien
intelligent
donc si tu les aimes tu ne t'es pas
choqué que t'es pas surpris qu'il dise
ça moi il est exactement comme il a
toujours été tout prend où tu laisses
fait je n'étais pas chez les jaunes et
en public
il donne une image contraire après 13 m
ha mais pas du tout est oublié
moi j'ai sauté je suis tombé sur une
interview qui donnait en 2016 où il
disait que tf1 l'avait laissé vraiment
sur la bord le bord de la route dans la
merde
ces huit lui tend la main il a fait un
très bon score et c'est quelqu'un que
j'adore et je trouve que c'est une très
très bonne idée d'avoir pris sur ces
villes là je suis choquée par ces
exigences
21h12 ça je trouve qu'il en fait trop et
il a pris le melon sa peau que c'est un
professionnel d'abord bien il a envie
qu'on respecte les horaires c'est pour
le succès de l'émission c'est pour rien
d'autre
c'est pas un caprice de star 5 ap c'est
un mec qui connaît bien la télévision et
qui a envie que ça reste globalement on
peut comprendre qu'il préfère que ça
qu'annonce le plus tôt possible qu'ils
aient un bond ce faire le dr d'audience
avec un gros programme avant qu'il
touche pas à mon poste
ouais ça peut s'entendre alors on vous a
posé la question est ce que vous êtes
choqués ou pas choquer la noria pas
choqué à
25% bah oui c'est quelque chose à dire
kabila qui laisse les dire que
généralement les plus exigeantes sont
les plus grands animateurs regarder
cyril un moment donné ou faut être faut
être exigeant c'est tout qu'est ce que
vous entendez par là les gens vont alors
se faire respecter
sa voix la direction exigeant et c'est
respecter aussi son public je veux dire
on a tous besoin d'avoir océans on peut
regarder un programme ça commence at
elle est alors alors même si son
programme commence à 21h30
mais qu'ils sachent que tous les soirs
où tous les mercredis ils commencent à
21h30
et puis c'est quelqu'un de très très
très mais très très populaire donc c'est
bien pour lui d'être sur ses 8 et c'est
bien pour ses 8 de la voir alors ils
voulaient peut-être faire avec sauf que
benjamin pardon mais la grande famille
c'est 8 laissez moi rire vous vous
souvenez de la gaffe quand il est venu
ici il a menacé son temps à parler de
fort boyard et dire que c'est
extraordinaire
quand il a fait la promesse sur france 2
quand il a fait l'émission ici aussi de
la rentrée de ses limites ils n'arrêtent
pas de dire justement et de marteler que
c'est un électron libre qui n'appartient
à personne qu'il est ici nulle part et
ailleurs donc vraiment il se singularise
et je pense qu'il veut montrer aussi qui
est le patron il avait l'habitude
d'avoir des énormes audience sûreté
faire 2 sur tf1
il se souvient pas enfin les la tnt
c'est quand même pas pareil sur gmail
oui mais j'ai lâché sans spahic martin
flores sortir l'oseille pour me garder
mais devraient être reconnaissants at-il
et l'on verra si ça commence à 21h il ya
pas de cinq autres séries mollement et
les limites